venez avec moi stéphane c'est très sain
aux fins qui aura la plus longue
spéciale canicule on va prendre tous les
deux un [ __ ] ici rural tirer ya bien
sûr c'est comme la courte paille temps
lui qui a la plus courte et bien voilà
celui qui a la plus longue d'ailleurs
pourra donc plus longue
voilà donc la voilà voilà on commence
avec ça choisissez prenez la rouge pas
mal je suis pas mal bon il est pas mal
non franchement je ne sais pas du tout
haha tu vois accord
ah pardon paix
ah ouais c'est la même chose que la
belle ait voté même quoi je réponds
jamais mais hot hot hot hot hot hot hot
garde qu'il dit là bas qui te plait
merci on a le deuxième point le deuxième
on doit sortir voilà la regarde et on va
aller dans plusieurs endroits là là là
regardez là on a ça c'est comme ça
qu'est comme ça d'accord aulas à ça il
faut que je réussisse eu alors vous
voulez que choisit son premier jeu vous
jouerais je sais rien du tout d'accord
achats sont pas du tout la musique est
formidable bien sûr harry s une cata
bien si elle saura troisième énorme
après merde non ça passe ça brasse
stoica
oh merde voilà bah c'est pas salé métro
par ses plats attention le qui aura la
plus longue
stéphane alesi choisissez le perdant
devra se mettre là et le gagnant aura
une petite tige et bien sûr voilà voilà
mais c'est très sympa vous inquiétez pas
il est là qui je l'aï cela parce que
c'est moi qui ai gagné alors allez-y
stéphane c'est un jeu digne de la taupe
alors j'y vais aller si je suis en
galère avec cette dijon
et bien sûr
alors
[Musique]
ma gueule égard alors stéphane allez je
vais me battre
coq là on y va sa rampe et et oui voilà
j'ai un deal à vous faire si vous si
vous prenez ma place demain je dirais
toutes les missions toutes les cinq
minutes qui a qui est la taupe sur m6 a
je crois je prends bon bah voilà allez
c'est bon bah voilà
allez merci et ben voila merci stéphane
les amis lui a coûté sa ministre le 10
sera porté par terre que j'attaque était
baden
[Applaudissements]